[Music]
some are calling it Joe Biden's last
stand and there's no doubt in the
importance of South Carolina's
Democratic primary to the former Vice
President Biden has history here and a
good relationship with African Americans
who make up 60% of Democratic voters
when nine worshippers were killed by a
white supremacist five years ago in
Charleston Biden stood alongside
President Obama to lend his support it's
that kind of connection that Biden is
touting eigvals they were making inroads
billionaire Tom Styer spent a fortune
winning political ads and gaining
traction Tom spider and Trump Gattaca
Biden's hopes of winning here are high
but South Carolina's black voters don't
speak with one voice african-american
Democratic voters are united in their
desire to see President Trump out of
office making them potentially more
pragmatic than loyal to just one
candidate the former vice president's
been falling in the polls his campaigns
tonight referring to the black vote as
their firewall then there's the
generation gap Bernie Sanders is doing
well with young black Millennials
further eating into Biden's wants
commanding lead yeah I'm bad because I
like Biden because of his views 56 year
old Loretta Maxwell is a Biden loyalist
daughter-in-law brillante is looking for
an alternative and Bernie could be her
candidate that's what a lot of young
black people a lot of young Millennials
are gravitating towards these days are
the progressive candidates not the
regular establishment candidates so I
think that's what Bernie brings to the
table and that's what makes him so
different as well on Wednesday Biden was
endorsed by congressman james Clyburn
long considered the Godfather of
democratic politics in this state it
could be a crucial seal of approval
among black voters I know Jill we know
Joe but most importantly you
knows us after early losses Saturday's
primary is a vital test for Biden he
can't just win here he needs to win big
we need real action in the White House
not not more lies
Andy Gallagher al Jazeera Charleston
South Carolina